on va quand même rappeler ces chiffres
en 2018 ils étaient 35 à se suicider 59
suicide en 2019 une hausse de 70% en un
an et déjà plusieurs cas notamment la
semaine dernière deux personnes qui se
sont suicidées tofu oui parce que la
violence policière la violence face à la
police des manifestants a commencé comme
quand même augmenté largement quand on
voit les les jets de projectiles de
pavés sur les forces de l'ordre
on a vu des manifestations où c'était
relativement violent alors je ne dis pas
que ces jeunes évidemment il ya les
black blocks sont nés qui joue ce rôle
de violence telle que je l'aï bien vu
que dans la société en général
on est dans une société qui est
nettement plus violente qu'elle a pu
l'être
on le voit avec des nombres d'élus mêmes
locaux qui se font agresser je suis
voire tuer puisqu'on a eu l'année
dernière quand même le maire de signes
qui est décédé un policier percuté un
cas un policier est percuté par un
camion
voilà les ministères défoncer avec des
des tractopelles ou pas des tracts
charles des transpalettes exactement
place et tout ça avec une police qui
quand même gardé un sang-froid et des
crs notamment qui sont formés pour cela
qu'ils gardent un sang froid hors du
commun
[Musique]